my glucose levels are already through
the roof this morning sugar is spiking 6
14 on a friday morning today is national
donut day a lot of local shops are
gearing up for a very busy day right now
and who better to take a donut challenge
than ron futrell he could talk sports he
can talk donuts he's a homer right a
homer in disguise joining us at glaze in
the southwest valley ron this is serious
business
homer simpson does love his donuts as do
i here we're back in the mix right we're
in the bowels of glazed doughnuts here
we're mixing them up right now
yes we are does that look good that's
fresh as could be this is fort apache
southwest part of the valley fort apache
and
sunset sunset d husband is joining us
here you're single though you're called
the husband but here yeah i'm sorry just
checking on that okay
i'm not single man no you're not okay
you are the husband okay yeah here we go
what's your favorite donuts here what
are we got so these are actually um some
of our most popular ones right here um
this is going to be our horchata donut
right here with the churro on top it's
going to be a horchata icing got enough
sugar on that one with the churro hey
listen we got to put a lot of sugar on
there for you they got cinnamon
sprinkles on top as well man okay now
you got green doughnuts come on now
green doughnuts hey listen this right
here this is a a really really popular
one as well this is our green tea
pistachio doughnut actually um
it's a unique flavor man so yeah yeah
okay uno mas we got one more here this
one this one really looks good this one
this is actually my favorite one right
here this is a too faced donut there's
salted caramels and pecans i love this
right here man these little pearls right
there is the salted caramel parts should
i try this one yeah i think you should
try this one right here right here boss
so you got caramel and nuts on what size
of caramel the brown side is going to be
the salted caramel and then the pecans
the other side
there you go
oh no that's good stuff and the salt
salt on there is good yeah okay you got
some for yeah man i got some donuts you
got to take back to the guys down at the
uh
office man these are for joe right
should we take this yeah take him to joe
man and let him chime so he can give us
some feedback on them keep your hands
awake man
[Laughter]
it's national donut day glazed donuts
this is we're doing all the all the
one-off donut places not the chain
places but the one that just has one
place glaze has one place they cook them
back here fresh
fort apache and sunset
no this i got d husband i got to tell
you this caramel with the nuts is is the
is the bomb is the choice is it what's
the cool thing to say it's it's highly
addictive that's what i say
[Laughter]
very highly addictive but that's that's
dee's favorite right there man okay
you've got a busy day for you national
donut day
we're here working it out a lot happened
we are cooking we're in the mix we're
trying some donuts we're getting fat
with a pee right all right so there we
go we'll be i got another place i got to
get to i'm hoping to obey most traffic
laws on my way to the next stop we'll
let you know when we get there but it's
the oldest donut shop in las vegas we're
on our way
i like this pecans are one of my
favorite things so it works out that
sounded like sweet and savory going on
there yes that was good ron i have a
quick request can we make d husband a
regular fixture of this morning show
he's awesome yes d husband they want you
okay they're telling me back in the
station they want you to be a regular
fixture like
a donut
that's a yes when you taste these
when you taste these you'll really want
that all right fair enough i can't see
the bomb though come on ron can you save
his donuts
can you say that sure
yes we can yes
[Music]
don't give me something to report on um
the pecan and salsa caramel there's a
two good combo right there i mean
no you're saying no to that no i'm all
about it yeah heather was drooling at
the green tea
pistachio one too but the churro as well
well you got one with a churro on top
coming your way